mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir ici l'elysée montmartre alors
qu' on pourrait se croire ici au théâtre
ce soir mais pas du tout rassurez vous
ce derby sportif ce n'est pas du théâtre
que nous allons voir où ça vaut tout au
moins si on voit du théâtre ce sera un
théâtre tout à fait spéciale puisque
nous sommes donc à l'elysée montmartre
un joli lieu du guépard hills où dans
les années 1900 on venait danser la
valse et le tango avec élégance et
distinction mais où ça allait le voir
grâce aux caméras de jean-michel pour
amener et
de la société française de production
non pratique maintenant entre deux
spectacles de variétés une jeune femme
moderne du tout rentrer luche ont
disparu car ici c'est le temple du catch
ce n'est ni monsieur montréal ni un
cavirac ocha qui sont en train de se
dire et de se faire des gentillesses
quand vous le voyez en ce moment sur le
ring qui me démentiront monsieur
montréal c'est celui qui est en l'air et
que celui qui est en bas maintenant
alors que 1 cavirac ocha c'est l'autre
le moustachu
il ya environ vingt minutes qu'ils sont
en train de de s'apostropher gentiment
sur le ring de l'elysée montmartre
alors qu'1 qu'a fait une clé dans le dos
à monsieur montréal ce sont deux poids
lourds
lesieu montréal 1 m 73 99 kg 1 cavirac
ocha ahmed 78 95 kg et monsieur
l'arbitré nerfs
monsieur l'arbitré qui s'appelle
monsieur jean louis marc est s'énerve il
crie plus fort que les catcheurs est
plus fort que le public ait une
manchette et une deuxième manche est sur
la tête et une troisième manche est
monsieur montréal n'en peut plus
monsieur montréal a dit arrête mais je
crois qu'un quart à continuer il
continue sur la tête
double nelson
et oui c'est le salaire lourds comme ça
99 kg mais pour un casse n'a rien du
tout jamais une plume monsieur montréal
essaye de récupérer
il s'appelle mon vieux montréal mais
n'est pas canadien il a eu le titre du
une sorte de monsieur muscle au canada
c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle monsieur
montréal et voilà quant à l'autre c'est
un cas un vrai un vrai péruvien
et le pérou et au tapis pour l'instant
oh la la
le pérou
et c'est maintenant monsieur montréal
qui apparemment cha cha qu'à son retour
après tout il a l'air méchant un cas un
cas est née à lima
monsieur o montréal est né à flers dans
l'orne c'était loin l'un de l'autre ils
se sont retrouvés sur un ring
il aurait mieux fait de rester au pérou
[Applaudissements]
et ça lui fait mal
regardez comme ils sous une petite
manchette
on répond on essaye de répondre
c'est un chacun et une chacun plus tôt
et que je te donne une et or prend une
autre à ça va donner quelque chose de
bizarre on a eu peur
2 et 3 c'est terminé
et bien voilà c'est le gentil c'est le
bon monsieur montréal qui a gagné ce qui
nous a permis de rentrer tout de suite
dans le
vif du sujet cette fan combat un cas est
complètement groggy
[Musique]
il a encore un genou à terre
et voilà marcel moral de son vrai nom
marcel chauveau vainqueur
il voudrait bien qu'on applaudisse un
cas mais on n'applaudira pas on
applaudira les suivants ceux qui vont
entrer maintenant sur le ring pour un
match à quatre ils vont arriver
et voilà
il s'appelle caber hassouni et claude
roch à ce seront peut-être les monts
[Musique]
sûrement les bons car les autres ont
l'air bien plus méchant les autres et
voici
il s'agit de bernard qatar le moustachu
barbus et de albert saliège un joli
kimono violaine seissannaise voici
caméra sony on va le voir de poche de
plus près kbr a su ni claude rocha et sa
nièce kkr
et voici monsieur rocard à sony
[Applaudissements]
c'est lui c'est son ami et c'est
monsieur jean-louis marais skhira
nouveau arbitrer ce combat alors que je
signale pour la petite histoire qu'il
était prévu que kbr hassouni soient
associés
son ami el alami qui est d'ailleurs
derrière moi mais qui est blessé ce soir
et qui ne cache pas il sera donc
remplacé par claude roch a peu de
requins dont on surveille attentivement
les semelles par l'intermédiaire de
monsieur l'arbitré à lebouc le book de
sa nièce ne plaît pas à tout le monde je
suppose que vous l'entendez je pense
qu'il va avoir des ennuis le boucle de
sa nièce
on verra bien j'espère tirer la
moustache alors on explique on dit qu'il
faut il bien gentils bien sage mais ça
m'étonnerait que parmi les quatre
personnages qui sont pour l'instant sur
le ring il y en ait plus de 2 qu'ils
soient bien sage
il faut noter si vous avez
la couleur le très joli maillot slip de
messieurs ça niaise et 4 l'art c'est
violet vert jaune c'est superbe
en noir et blanc ça va être pas mal non
plus en tout cas pour l'instant sur le
ring avec ce maillot bizarre style
panthères c'est ça niaise et de l'autre
côté c'est claude roch a alors on
commence doucement doucement
voici douze mois que ça pour l'instant
roccat ça niaise alors que les deux
autres sont calmement dans dans leur
coin en attendant de prendre la relève
assez joli applaudissent par des
connaisseurs
il est parti deux fois en l'air mais
c'est un voltigeur 0 k il continue
voltiger
voilà alors on a changé d'un côté on
change de l'autre à monsieur hassouni à
l'air nerveux
qui est le plus nerveux des de ce que
c'est à sony ou est ce que ces quatre là
ce sont des voltigeurs c'est un combat
de poids légers vais vous donner les
poids de chacun vous verrez
caméra sony 72 kg john rocha 76 kg
bernard 4 77 kg albert sa nièce 73 kg
c'est à thouars qui permet de voler et
il vole à l'arbitrage était un petit peu
piégé là ça niaise contre à sony a sonné
champion du maroc et c'est lui qui fait
du mal au moustachu barbu kader hassouni
à 35 ans contre monsieur sow niaise 35
ans également 35 contre 35
mais le 35 duo pour l'instant est plus
fort que le 35 du bas est ce qu'il va
arriver à se dégager ce brave monsieur
sa nièce
voilà ben ça s'arrange pas quelques
larmes jacques l'art est à nouveau à
terre alors c'est chacun son tour
pour l'instant quatre là on se retrouve
à terre c'est sa position favorite et la
prusse favorite de caméras sony
semble-t-il c'est cette clé dans le dos
et un petit coup dans le ventre et on se
fait remplacer monsieur à sony se fait
remplacer par monsieur claude rocha
alors qu'on dit toujours le seul arbitre
monsieur l'abbé qui compte pour
l'instant il ne compte pas pas très loin
il s'arrête souvent à 3 oui même pas 2
cette fois bernard guetta qui essaye de
se venger sur claude roch a de ce qu'il
n'a pu faire sur khadr a sous doute pas
là
[Applaudissements]
le prend parce qu'il aime
là mon bébé est pas
ah non ça suffit pas
et retour dans le personnel à 1063
monsieur daniel gentil dans le civil il
porte des lunettes
mais il est évident qu'il vaut mieux les
retirer pour ce genre d'exercice ce
qu'il a fait pour amant et ce samedi aux
états styliste et regarder ça quel style
un petit pont
[Applaudissements]
et voilà c'est une nouvelle figure
acrobatique
c'est un joli ballet
[Applaudissements]
ils dansent sur le sol
en tout cas ça niaiser prisonnier par
les jambes de john rocha s'agit bien de
s'en défaire de ses jambes
il essaye mais monsieur rocard n'entend
pas aussi haut ici le public est aux isp
et monsieur ça niaise mais n'y arrivent
voilà un joli dégagement on cherche dans
la complication
voilà c'est des sports monsieur ça ne
vient pas à non à qu'est ce que ça va
vite on fait dans la complication passer
des âmes est comme ça a été très
compliqué
et on a changé
il en a trouvé cas d incendie avec son
maillot blanc contre bernadette avec son
beau frère et avec un bon coup dans le
ventre
[Applaudissements]
quant à monsieur n'habite il ne sait
visiblement confié que jusqu'à trois
pour l'instant à 100 tout à oui on avait
dit de stats de ces classes uniques il
était très habile très agile et ses
vraies petites plaies au cou
est ce que tu lui fais dit quelqu'un
côté de moi une petite fille au cou a
sourit tape avec ses jambes
tiens khadr à terre khadr et je sens
qu'il va y avoir des problèmes avec la
barbe de monsieur bernard cac large vous
le disais tout à l'heure mais ça pourra
pas durer longtemps comme ça il ya bien
des deux méchants qui va en vouloir
sérieusement
la part de monsieur kkr avait monsieur
kaka une bonne souplesse
ce n'est pas ça parce qu'il gêne mais
pas trop si les chiffres une série
et en l'air mais ce cas car est sorti
c'est sa devise est rentré il subit le
même sort et
sa prise à kader galère est sorti
il y avait assorti son coéquipier qui
était rentré
envoyer son adversaire donc il est
revenu il aurait mieux fait de rester
dehors parce que ça se passe mal pour
lui
[Musique]
ils sont coincés tous les deux c'est
celui qui dépensera l'autre alors est ce
qu'ils sont en train de chercher à se
faire mal ou en train de chercher à se
décoincer tout le problème est là
voilà vous voyez il ya des pieds par
tous trois y en a quatre gros que ça
fait mal ah oui il a mal ça va faire
très très mal
je vous conseille ça pour la gymnastique
le matin soit excellent double nelson de
monsieur rocard sur monsieur ça niaise
et on va recommencer et voilà on essaye
en tout cas annoncé l'autre maintenant
et on vole on vole un deux et on arrête
là 12.23 tel est le refrain de l'échelle
arbitres
à
on a voulu piéger
[Applaudissements]
une petite clé de bernard cathelat
claude roch a les bras à chaque fois
qu'il essaye de se dégager ils n'y
arrivent pas bien le bras de monsieur k
claret plus solide encore que le bla le
vent de monsieur rocard à il était bien
dans toutes les positions ça il a réussi
et public connaisseur applaudi et du
coup il s'est fait remplacer kaka est
maintenant s'il vous plaît beaucoup
les au coût de claude cassure personnes
yeahs qui a remplacé quelques uns se
sont tous des voltigeurs
alors que ça fait dix minutes qui sont
en train d'essayer de se faire mal
d'essayer de gagner ici sur le ring de
l'elysée montmartre
lisez mon mari qui est tenu par l'ancien
catcheur roger delaporte l'infâme de la
porte
vous vous souvenez sans doute à femmes
sur le ring car dans la vie c'est un
personnage très sympathique
ainsi d'ailleurs que tous ces catcheurs
qui il se bat ce soir sympathique dans
la vie parfois un peu mes chansons live
où il faut savoir choisir secrétaire
hassouni à bien des ennuis en ce moment
maintenant c'est l'autre cas dès
aujourd'hui il est tellement d'ennui qui
préfèrent se faire remplacer ça niaise
les catllar revient dakhla contre
hassouni maillot blanc
[Applaudissements]
vas-y des publics on s'endort un petit
peu là c'est joli mais faudrait forcer
notre qu'ils forcent à sony et que cac
la force aussi alors qu'on attend
roulement de tambour on se parent est au
cirque
mesdames et messieurs regardez la belle
kelly que je dis fais et regarder
comment je m'en des faits et regarder
comment je la refais et regarder comment
je mords des faits et regarde et on
recommence
et ben en fait le tambour elle a été
jusqu'à quatre arbitres cette fois ci et
on reprend la main une petite main
blanche de caméras sony sur pernod
ricard
il a l'air de souffrir car ça lui plaît
pas ah oui comme échanges et la change
[Applaudissements]
rien
il lui a offert sa main voilà qui
doit pas sa main mais c'était pour mieux
prendre la main de l'autre
et s'énerve ça niaise voici calberson et
s'énerve de voir monsieur l'arbitré ne
se fait pas ça à séduire sortie et c'est
claude rocha qui rentrait du coup samia
je préfère sortir et laisser sa place à
kacla et une petite clé dans le dos à
l'avènement au le beau brun et voilà
c'est fini on recommence on essaye de
recommencer main dans la main c'est
touchant
allez olla voilà là
coup de pied assassins on paye dans le
plu oui ce kacla un assassin pourtant un
catcheur consciencieux appliquer un peu
têtu part active
en tout cas il aime bien donner des
coups pieds et claude roch à l'écouté il
n'aime pas ça les coups de poing non
plus d'ailleurs
alors on tire lait et ils sont à deux
maintenant pas moi du cac leur voilà
alors ils se changent à chaque fois
qu'il change y en a un qui reste un
petit peu plus longtemps que prévu qui
permet de faire encore plus de mal à
claude rocha et il a mal requins en ce
moment et oui ça lui fait tellement mal
que ça lui fait du bien comme dit
à côté et 102 sél entrant truc c'est
beaucoup plus pratique à deux contre un
requin en peut plus quant à kader
hassouni les dents sans quoi ils sont si
j'y vais ou j'y vais pas dire et où j'y
vais pas il est à part
ah la la
axa liesse monte sur le ring pour venir
aider son ami cac l'art et ça me fait
toujours par cas
les cadets réside toujours et le public
a beau lui dire vas-y kader kader n'y va
pas c'est bien à y aller
on savait bien on sentait bien que
d'aller y aller
un pli pour chaque d'eau 1 contre 1 et 2
contres et maintenant voilà ça commence
monsieur l'arbitré a beau parler à
monsieur sam hier monsieur sa nièce
battante que monsieur l'arbitré de
tournée et il va revenir et voilà
et oui est revenue et un avertissement à
voilà ça lui apprendra
[Applaudissements]
voilà voilà ce que c'est d'être méchant
et de ne pas respecter les règlements
il n'a pas trempé visiblement car ils
recommencent dans un homme averti en
vaut deux comme ils sont deux avertis ça
fait 4 4 contre 1 vous rendez compte
quatre heures a bien mal à je crois
croqua va se dégager à la voilà ce que
c'est d'être méchant il a voulu plonger
il a voulu plonger mercat était parti et
il s'est fait mal
le crime est toujours puni
rk prend sa revanche il sourit on le
voit sourire d'ici là doit dire chalet
bien que je t'aurais ils le traînent sur
levante pas mon prêt une brouette
voilà c'est beaucoup plus joli comme ça
boyer brouette en arrière ça doit vous
rappeler certains travaux quand vous
êtes à la campagne voilà on charrie un
petit peu le gravier
[Applaudissements]
voulez vous
il se retire de cette fâcheuse situation
un joli petit pont est c'est un petit
peu un grand pont troyen pons a une
histoire de viaduc a laissé le dit
l'arbitré rocha et si le cheval vais
essayer de se relever que je le compte
et on reprend le pied de même le droit
pas pour longtemps mais la phase i test
dans allait bien dutil seissannaise il a
dit aqa clavien donc ici ça n'aura passé
qu'un avertissement
mais monsieur rocha s'est vengé
quant à monsieur hassouni le marocain il
est au chômage pour l'instant on sait
pas qui même lui demander gentiment ils
viendraient bien voilà je sentais qu'ils
moi monsieur j'ai rien fait
[Applaudissements]
par les cheveux
qui moi monsieur j'ai rien fait ainsi
est-il le champion d'afrique du nord
quatre heures à sony il fait comme s'il
n'avait rien fait
mais celle arbitres le vrai temps en
temps
des caméras de jean michel cormier et la
société française de production on le
voit aussi hassouni
regardez le il boite personne de voir
mais on voit et il attache sa chaussure
sur les filins du ring et voilà à il
s'est décroché tout de même
aïe aïe aïe
qu'est ce que ça fait mal et hassouni
maintenant on va pouvoir travailler au
grand jour et non pas dans son petit
coin comme tout à l'heure alors que
c'est maintenant
rocard
[Applaudissements]
il va y vas pas à illies arrêté mais il
a fait mal à son ami sortait rocade il
arbitres
enfin monsieur rocard pour l'instant ces
caméras sony qui al'avantage avantages
d'une jambe et monsieur rocha vient
[Applaudissements]
et monsieur sam yeh monsieur lannoy
revient maintenant chacun son tour
[Applaudissements]
ils sont tantôt 2 quant aux trois tantôt
il voudrait bien se défiler il a réussi
à se défiler sa nièce pour ce faire on
passait par quatre l'art qui revient à
l'air méchant regardant larbi et en
ayant l'air de dire alors quoi nous vous
nous avez donné un avertissement et a eu
vous leur donnez pas qu'est ce que ça
veut dire et 20 minutes et un qu'il
arbitre mais ils recommencent à chaque
fois pas facile il faut les et pour le
bien par terre et il jolie paix au cou
kader hassouni sur bernard kkr qui sont
nées des faits et qui a pris les pieds
du maracana sony
khadr à sony qui est d'une grande
courtoisie dans la vie et qui vient de
passer le relais à son ami rocha qui lui
est un bon époux est évocateur vodka à
une petite fille
il est fonctionnaire municipal et il a
un grand défaut à part celui de recevoir
des manchettes sur le ring c'est
d'arriver en retard tous les matins au
bureau mais son chef de service ne lui
fait pas des manches et rome sarroca
quand et par tard rk sort et est
remplacé par à sony ça va vite ça va
très vite
à
ils pas droit était très à gauche parce
que si la taper
[Applaudissements]
on avait raté un petit l'objectif
pendant quelques instants
mais le dernier coup vu le bon est
tellement bon que c'est maintenant katla
qui est revenue sur le ring contre à
sony et des petits coups de tête d'à
sony et monsieur rocard revient aux
rocha a les deux genoux dans la figure
de sa nièce pour qui c'est trop et
qu'ils demandent
le secours de c'était kacla rapidement
des secours depuis que sa nièce
maintenant il revient aux origines
il revient pour pour goûter le sol on
essaye de culbuter et en culbute
[Applaudissements]
alors là on peut pas le contrôler il n'a
pas les épaules bien fixée ça vole
beaucoup mais troisième est raté voilà
ce que c'est le rap et 1,2 à la sas
épitaphe et interdit tout à fait
interdit le ciel arbitres atteints en
train de compter les 4 heures est venu
déranger le compte de l'arbitrage c'est
quand est ce que si j'ai l'impression
que cette fois il a compté jusqu'à 3 est
ce qu'il va dire monsieur l'arbitré ce
qu'il a compté jusqu'à 3 mai ou non et
oui il dit oui
il a dit oui
il a dit oui et monsieur sa nièce dit
non mais monsieur l'arbitré dit me
[Applaudissements]
alors voilà
la première manche et non pas par les
gentils entre parenthèses
claude roch 1 et kader à sony à la suite
d'une décision de le seul arbitre
[Applaudissements]
compté jusqu'à 3 watts en dise monsieur
ça niaise il est évident que si monsieur
catllar bien arrêté le 10 ans de
larbitre il n'y arrivera jamais chez
l'habitant
nous allons donc pour assister à la
deuxième manche deuxième manche de ce
combat de catch as catch on prend les
conseils des soigneurs on essaye de se
concentré avant de reprendre sa nièce
était tellement en colère à l'heure il a
l'air méchant quand il remporte
rencontre d'autres cas ah oui la vermine
chant et pas par les cheveux du arbitres
d'accord alors des manchettes manchettes
et il somme est à deux contre un et toi
de requins n'aiment pas ça ils sont
écroulées de contre un troisième manche
et ça fait mal d'eux dans le ventre et
dans le dos une petit devant une petite
devant encore à leur retour du bâton
comme un boomerang bernard catllar
contre john rocha cac l'ars et le
maillot bizarroïde de toutes les
couleurs et roca c'est le maillot rouge
foncé si vous avez de noir et blanc et
on a changé car est sorti et sa nièce
est revenu il le marches sur le dos ils
lui volent sans levante un appel
arbitres s'est arrêté là
alors là c'est
c'est une bonne scène d'amour
[Applaudissements]
comme toutes les scènes d'amour ça peut
se terminer mal et ça c'est un minimale
par pour albert ça niaise
[Applaudissements]
il va mal albert ça niaise alors il
s'est fait remplacer les têtes noires
est revenue et on repart à chacun dans
un ancien corps du ring ils vont finir
par se rencontrer à a arrêté net
et monsieur kader assouly sommet en
hérisson pour que bernard tacleur ne
puisse pas les femmes mais attention
qui s'y frotte s'y pique
[Applaudissements]
là encore bien
et bien dans quelques lardin un
avertissement arbitres ça c'est
extraordinaire
vous pénètre dans son élan ouah albert
sa nièce étape
eric taver hassouni le regard l'aï noir
un noir regarde albert sa nièce et celui
là sony et en profite pour le mettre un
peu dans les cordes il a eu du mal à
sortir et tu vas voir tu vas voir la
satire de dit tu vas voir il a vu le
souffle coupé calais racing superbe
manchette il va y en avoir une deuxième
la voilà une troisième
[Applaudissements]
et une 4e avant de
à
passé le relais à bernard cathelat
qu'est ce qu'il va faire caca sony n'en
peut plus continuer avec des manchettes
son ami ça niaise avait commencé avec
des manches et continuer avec des
manches et une petite dans le ventre une
petite part le dos il a 80 dating est
oui or et qui se lève
est-ce qu'il peut se lever
mais non il peut soit se grassi peut se
lever les deux bouts il est même bien
debout
voilà regarder filer le bout
il a réussi à se donner et il a réussi à
se faire remplacer
alors maintenant ça va être la fête à
kaka non c'est pas la fête à caque là
c'est la très tard au ko sur le banc de
requins cinq à dix arbitres
il en faudrait encore 5,2 war 3
seulement cette fois-ci propulsé oiseaux
d'euros ça se retrouve
coco rocha est toujours intéressé très
content et plusieurs fois il pas d'une
fatwa une maquette une phase 5
or m usd par terre à chaque fois qu'ils
sont heureux puisqu'il se relève il
retombe alors visiblement il ne tient
plus debout là me retient alors que le
public réclame la présence de caméras
sur le ring mais kbr est un sage il
respecte les règlements il reste donc en
dehors du ring c'est pas l'envié qui lui
remonte pourtant
regardez le il y va presque mais vous
sortir larbitre
il s'en prend
[Applaudissements]
elle a compté jusqu'à 3
réussi
à côté
d'attenté claude rocquelin jusqu'à 3 et
ce n'est pas de l'avis de tout le monde
car monsieur l'arbitré avec dos tourné
pendant ce temps là alors évidemment
c'est facile si bien qu'on en ait une
manche partout et on reprend rocha et on
le transporte un paquet d'un châle ice
entière
ils peuvent un tiers c'est du joli
profité de l'absence de l'arbitré pour
gagner larbi s'étaient éclipsés
ils sont montés à 2 g quand il est venu
l'arbite il y en avait plus qu'un et
c'était facile à ce moment-là compté
jusqu'à 3 et oui que voulez-vous il
triche
ils ont triché ils ont triché mais j'en
gagnais cette deuxième manche
et comme la première a été remportée par
les autres il y en aura donc une autre
d'une troisième entre kader hassouni
associé à claude roch à notre père
nakata que voici le moustachu et albert
saliège une manche partout
inutile de vous dire que le public n'est
pas content il s'assoit merci jean
michel pommier alors que le loyer la
jolie moustache de roger delaporte au
premier rang roger delaporte le catcheur
qui faisait plaisir à tous les amis
sportifs devient une quinzaine d'années
sur les rings de l'elysée montmartre et
d'ailleurs alors que la partie pour la
troisième manche
[Applaudissements]
saliès contre rocha défend toile du
temps à rocha qui essayerait bien de se
défendre s'il en avait les possibilités
mais il n'a même pas le temps de
souffler à peine debout ça repart et
quand ce n'est pas ça niaise ces quatre
là jack là ça va devenir l'horrible cas
car elle est bien dit il à son ami 1
voilà ça lui apprendra et caméras sony
est rentré pour venger rocha et ils le
vendent bien et une tête et il venge en
prenant l'autre à la 1 contre e2 ça me
fait pas peur dit il
et
[Applaudissements]
à tête à tête
et du coup monsieur l'arbitré pull en
herbe faire sortir monsieur cadeau si
elle sourit et il veut faire sortir il
va donner un avertissement pour lui
avoir pour lui apprendre à ne pas faire
entrer deux catcheurs sur le ring daclin
josé rocha qui revient ils ont le vent
en poupe à suzuka et il en profite ce
relais avec le sourire et avec fougue
tellement que monsieur cac la vapeur et
les sorties bernard cathelat est sorti
du ring et il revient
[Applaudissements]
il revient pour se venger
il y monte sur le court
s'appuie sur les ports de roca est venu
roca est venu pour aider son ami à soli
et il a réussi
alors qu'on persiste à combattre roger
delaporte entre londres aucun tout le
monde s'y met l'arbitré descend du
parterre
tout le monde se bat ah la la est-ce
qu'on va aller à monter regardé comme de
la porte est en colère
la porte il a dit c'est fini pour moi
sur la tête qu'est ce qu'on vient
embêter
à
voilà le combat se déroule sur le ring
mais pendant un moment c'était devant
leurs
mais personne ne savait qui était qui il
y avait un arbitre il y avait de la
porte il y avait les quatre catcheurs
il y avait une jeune fille blonde qui se
demandait ce qu'elle faisait là
mais tout est entré dans l'eau et les
catcheurs son solo ring est le seul
arbitre aussi et une manchette a souri
sur kaka 2007 1,6 au tout gros ça fait
mal
[Applaudissements]
cette plainte pastore à daniel bouton a
et celle intense du scot
j'y vais dire sony lilas et que je te
comprends et je tombais un coup dans le
ventre
[Applaudissements]
la main dans la main la main dans l'eau
c'est celui qui aura les pectoraux les
plus solides
respectant les plus enivrants ceux de la
sony puisqu'il a réussi à m
la liesse par terre alors que ces
roquets maintenant qui reprend la niaise
alors que quelqu'un arrive qu'est ce
qu'on veut ce cas cavaillon qu'est ce
que vous faites là l'habitude qu'on ne
regarde pas tout la beauté jusqu'à 2 et
oui on peut pas compter regardez de
s'apprécier
camara
[Applaudissements]
investissement à quatre là ça lui
apprendra inventé sur le ring quand il
n'a pas d'autorisation au court dans
tous les sens pas ce que ça va donner
est-ce qu'ils vont se rencontrer ils se
rencontrent au désavantage de cadarache
il est fier de lui albert sagnier
d'avoir fait ça le triomphe modeste et
on recommence petites courses on le
vilain geste
oh le vilain geste
[Applaudissements]
oh
albert sani de la niaise albert sagnier
il en est resté par terre il s'est fait
remplacer kaka contre rockhal je sens
que la barbichette c'est pour bientôt
stop dit yves et pendant le don à ça
c'est de la mauvaise foi
il lui dit d'arrêter il recommence ça va
se passer autrement avec les races unis
[Applaudissements]
un petit ciseau coup en passant est elle
perçue agnès revient rangers et méchant
et caméras sony
c'est là dedans c'est la danse de
coincer une centenaire de scalps pièce
qui va le remporter
et oui mais à chaque fois ils se mettent
à 2 comment voulez-vous qu'il compte
monsieur arbitres
il n'y arrivera jamais alors il faut
recommencer et on recommence on
retravaille
on retourne à la bagarre et c'est une
manchette par ci une manchette parle à
chacun son tour un avis ça fait mal
évidemment 1 2 et 3 ouais
[Applaudissements]
et ils ont gagné et on arrête là
un à gauche bernard cathelat rial
personnes ayant perdu et kader à sony
john rocha ont gagné
et le public en est content de cette
victoire
j'avais adopté caméra sony étonnant car
ils sont gagnés c'est très bien ainsi
c'est une justice il ya une justice dans
le catch et c'est parfait
et bien c'est sûr c'est peu
victoire de kader à sony et de claude
rocha devant bernard cathelain et albert
sa nièce qui voudrait bien être
vainqueur
à
que nous avons et nous allons vous
laisser et si l'élysée moment avons
restitué
[Musique]